it's a new week and that means new games
are coming out there might be a few more
than you think so let's start with the
gut-wrenching story of humanity on the
brink of extinction due to some crazy
naked Giants its attack on Titan the
player controls Eren Mikasa Armin and
other members of the survey corpse in
their 3d mg's hacking the next of those
vicious tighten the computer will
control allies who fight alongside the
player and if the Allies are captured
the player can rescue them by cutting
the Titans arms off of what humans are
eaten it's gonna be gross you're gonna
be able to pick this up in North America
on the 12th for thirty nine ninety nine
next up the turn-based tactical game
that stealthily moves from early access
into full release invisible ink you
might find comparisons with XCOM as you
select agents for missions get close to
them and then watch in horror as they
die in battle with permadeath and
procedurally generated levels it might
take some time and patience to make the
most of this but you'll find that your
efforts are greatly rewarded the
fantastic combination of stealth
strategy and tactics makes invisible ink
a good option this week and you can
start your mission on the 12 moving
right along xbox one owners get the
truly interesting story of lifeless
planet you're a scientist on a mission
to research life but your ship crashes
and you lose all your crew members as
hinted in the title the planet is not
covered in life but in fact devoid of it
but there are secrets to uncover you can
learn more of the platforming and puzzle
solving in this game that I think the
mystery is some of its charm so you can
find out for yourself on the 13th the
sequel to 2006's Galactic Civilizations
to dreadlords is finally coming out of
early access this week Galactic
Civilizations 3 is the latest
installment of the space strategy game
build an empire that dominates the
galaxy through conquest diplomacy
cultural hegemony or scientific research
and you'll have to balance expansion
exploration and the Alban inevitable
galactic warfare it's currently
scheduled for release on the 14th
playstation announced a few indie titles
that i'm going to burn through pretty
quickly first is nom nom galaxy that's
coming to ps4 on the 12th this week the
goal is to basically create giant soup
factories and ship soup to people in
outer space it's a blend of tower
defense sandbox exploration co-op
platforming resource management and
construction we also get color guardians
on ps4 and Vita an endless runner that
adds the twist of switching out your
character to match the color of the
blobs you're collecting you can pick up
this cutely styled game on the 14th
PlayStation also gives this torrent an
adventure game with little to no
dialogue where you adventure and learn
new abilities as your character ages you
can become moonchild on the 12th not a
hero comes out of the woodwork this week
from the developers of Olly Olly roll 7
the cover based shooter follows a
professional assassin turned amateur
campaign manager as he cleans up the
city with bullets the game is set to
release on the 14 inside my radio is a
rhythm action platformer adventure that
makes you fight to the beat you're a
green LED mysteriously trapped inside of
a dying boombox out to save music so
similarly to crypt of the necrodancer
you put on some headphones and move with
the music you can bust out a beat on the
11th finally project cars comes out on
current-gen consoles so you might want
to finally pick up that wheel you've
been eyeing with some aggressive
handling and an insane tuning setup
screen you might feel a little
intimidated but stick with it for that
reward of leaving other racers in the
dust that's on the 12 oh I think that's
all the games this week for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week